Prenez l'invention moderne qui est peut-être la plus importante :
les ordinateurs programmables.
L'histoire habituelle est
que les ordinateurs descendent d'une technologie militaire,
car les premiers ordinateurs étaient spécialement conçus
pour craquer des codes de guerre ou calculer la trajectoire d'un missile.
Mais, en fait, les origines de l'ordinateur moderne
sont beaucoup plus ludiques,
voire musicales,
que vous ne l'imaginez.
L'idée derrière la flûte,
de pousser l'air dans des tubes pour produire un son,
a fini par être modifiée pour créer le premier orgue
il y a plus de 2 000 ans.
Quelqu'un a eu la brillante idée de déclencher des sons
en pressant de petites manettes avec nos doigts,
inventant le premier clavier musical.
Les claviers ont évolué de l'orgue au clavicorde, au clavecin,
au piano,
jusqu'au milieu du XIXe siècle,
quand un groupe d'inventeurs a finalement eu l'idée
d'utiliser un clavier pour déclencher non pas des sons mais des lettres.
En fait, la première machine à écrire
était, à l'origine, appelée : « clavecin qui écrit ».
Les flûtes et la musique ont mené à des découvertes encore plus puissantes.
Il y a environ mille ans,
lors de l'apogée de la Renaissance islamique,
trois frères de Bagdad ont conçu un appareil
qui était un orgue automatisé.
Ils l'ont appelé « l'instrument qui joue tout seul ».
L'instrument était, en gros, une boîte à musique géante.
L'orgue pouvait être entraîné à jouer diverses chansons grâce à des instructions
encodées en plaçant des épingles sur un cylindre en rotation.
Si vous vouliez que la machine joue une autre chanson,
il suffisait de mettre un autre cylindre avec un code différent.
Cet instrument était le premier en son genre.
Il était programmable.
Conceptuellement, c'était un énorme pas en avant.
Toute l'idée du matériel et du logiciel
devient imaginable pour la première fois grâce à cette invention.
Ce concept incroyablement puissant
n'est pas apparu comme un instrument pour la guerre ou la conquête,
ni quelque chose de nécessaire.
Il a découlé de l'étrange plaisir de voir une machine jouer de la musique.
En fait, l'idée de machines programmables
a été maintenue en vie durant 700 ans exclusivement par la musique.
Dans les années 1700, les machines faisant de la musique
sont devenues les jouets de l'élite parisienne.
Les forains utilisaient les mêmes cylindres codés
pour contrôler les mouvements physiques de ce qu'ils appelaient « automata »,
le début des robots.
Un de ces robots les plus célèbres,
vous l'aurez deviné, était un joueur de flûte automatisé
conçu par un brillant inventeur français : Jacques de Vaucanson.
Alors que de Vaucanson concevait son robot musicien,
il a eu une autre idée.
S'il était possible de programmer une machine à faire des sons plaisants,
pourquoi ne pas la programmer à tisser de beaux motifs colorés sur des habits ?
Au lieu d'utiliser les aiguilles du cylindre
pour représenter des notes musicales,
elles représenteraient des fils de différentes couleurs.
Si vous vouliez un nouveau motif pour votre tissu,
il suffisait de programmer un nouveau cylindre.
C'était le premier métier à tisser programmable.
Les cylindres étaient trop chers et leur conception trop longue,
mais 50 ans plus tard,
un autre inventeur français du nom de Jacquard
eut la brillante idée d'utiliser des cartes de papier perforées
au lieu de cylindres métalliques.
Le papier s'est avéré être une façon de programmer l'appareil
moins chère et plus flexible.
Ce système de carte perforée a inspiré l'inventeur victorien Charles Babbage
pour créer sa machine analytique,
le premier ordinateur programmable
jamais conçu.
Et les cartes perforées ont été utilisées en programmation
jusque dans les années 70.
Posez-vous cette question :
qu'est-ce qui a rendu l'ordinateur moderne possible ?
Oui, l'implication militaire est une partie importante de l'histoire,
mais inventer un ordinateur a nécessité d'autres éléments :
les boîtes à musique,
les jouets joueurs de flûte,
les claviers de clavecin,
les motifs colorés sur du tissu
et ce n'est qu'une petite partie de l'histoire.
Il y a une longue liste d'idées et de technologies novatrices
qui ont joué un rôle :
les musées publics, le caoutchouc,
la théorie des probabilités, le secteur des assurances
et bien d'autres.
La nécessité n'est pas toujours la mère de l'innovation.
L'état d'esprit ludique est fondamentalement exploratoire,
il cherche de nouvelles possibilités autour de nous.
Et cette recherche fait que tant d'expériences
ayant débuté simplement avec plaisir et amusement
nous ont finalement menés à de profondes innovations.
Je pense que cela a des conséquences
sur l'enseignement de nos enfants à l'école,
comment nous encourageons l'innovation au travail
mais voir le jeu et le plaisir ainsi
nous aide aussi à détecter ce qui est à venir.
Pensez-y : si nous étions en 1750,
essayant de prévoir les grands changements à venir pour la société
lors des XIXe et XXe siècles,
les machines automatisées, les ordinateurs,
l'intelligence artificielle,
une flûte programmable
divertissant l'élite parisienne
aurait autant été un indice que tout autre chose de l'époque.
Cela semblait être, au mieux, un amusement,
ce n'était pas sérieusement utile,
mais cela s'est avéré être le début d'une révolution technologique
qui allait changer le monde.
Vous trouverez le futur
là où les gens s'amusent le plus.